in this video I'll be going over
examples of compliments so in this video
I've defined the universe to be the
integers 1 through 5 and it's denoted
graphically by this blue line and if we
recall the definition of the compliments
whether or with regards to a we have a
compliment equals the set containing
elements X such that X is an element of
the universe and X is not an element of
a so in that case we can look at all the
integers 1 through 5 and if it contains
any element from a we throw it out so in
this case if we look at the integer 1 we
know that that's not going to be there
because that's an a if we look at the
integer 2 that'll be in our set we look
at the integer 3 that won't be in our
set because that's also an egg and then
4 and 5 are within the universe and
they're not with an egg next we have B
complement well we know that 1 2 4 & 5
are within the universe and they're not
within B and lastly we have C complement
2 4 and 5 are within the universe and
they're not within C because we had to
exclude 1 & 3